[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce pays y fait dont
l'invité et reba haye a dit bonjour
alors il ya des curieux qui voulaient
est là pour vous et je suis ravi
d'accueillir ces verrines flv bonjour
vous êtes la présidente de startac qui
ne
rentre aux prises deux formations
continues au digital
et jean charles lajoie knees de qui est
éditeur qui se demandent si peut-être
dit est un livre sur vous dans quelques
temps le niveau qui s'appellera
championne d'europe voilà j'espère
signer et signé aussi par une championne
d'europe
et du monde peut-être peut-être
championnes olympiques on va savoir en
tout cas voilà rima vous êtes boxeuse
vous êtes championne de france pour
l'instant depuis depuis décembre 2020 et
championne continentale
oui que depuis la avril 2021 et j'ai
donc renouveler mon titre le 30 octobre
dernier voilà formidable et je parlais
des championnats d'europe puisque les
champions d'europe ont eu lieu
probablement au mois de mars vous êtes
un 20 février enfin très très
prochainement aux mureaux oui alors vous
êtes vous êtes membre du club du bureau
c'est ça vous même vous habitez à poissy
pourquoi le club des bureaux alors je
suis parisienne donc j'ai grandi à paris
mais le meilleur club de boxe anglaise
en france en tout cas en boxe
professionnelle est aux mureaux donc ils
ont été élus meilleurs clubs meilleur
entraîneur de france donc j'ai décidé de
prendre la route et de me rapprocher des
meilleurs alors à votre avis est ce
quelque autour des 10 h au club de
france et qu'elle ait tous les titres
qu'elle a commencé à la boxe depuis très
longtemps c'est un tome dont confondues
l'enfance à cinq ou six ans sakho 6 ans
ah c'est ça
j'ai commencé très tardivement j'ai
commencé à 26 ans en 2016 précisément ça
vous a pris comme ça à l'époque et pas
du tout sportif il faut dire que vous
aviez quoi 15 kilos de plus un vain
il n'y a pas de problème avec ça j'avais
20 kg de plus donc j'ai mais pas
spécialement allez vous étiez pas du
tout sportive non puis j'avais moi même
les préjugés que je combats aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que le sport c'est quelque
chose de trop dur trop difficile il ne
comprenait pas ces gens qui cherchaient
autant difficulté il y avait déjà cette
problème dans notre vie pour passer en
rajouter donc je n'aimais pas ça pour
masquer nos contraintes mais il a fallu
que je découvre en 2016 le sport que
j'ai un rendez vous avec la boxe comment
est ce que devenir addict comment ça
s'est passé ce rendez-vous pour pourquoi
la boxe parce que même quand on se dit
qu'ils envoient faire du sport s'inscrit
dans un club de gym aussi des problèmes
j'avais commencé par quelques cours de
gym pour pour perdre un peu de kilos et
à ce moment là j'étais serveuse dans un
resto et il y avait une équipe de
boxeurs qui venaient manger très
régulièrement après leur entraînement et
donc j'avais sympathisé avec eux et
l'entraîneur et l'entraîneur voilier à
ce moment là que comme je vive ya
quelques épreuves difficiles je pense
qu'il sentait que j'étais assez nerveuse
dès que j'avais besoin de me défouler
qu'il fallait que une activité dont il
me l'a souvent insisté pour que j'aille
les visités dans leur salle de boxe thaï
à l'époque donc j'ai un peu été poussés
sans trop de conviction au départ
mais lorsque je me suis initié au sac de
frappe pour la première fois là j'ai un
très très gros
une révélation c'est une révélation et
c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est ça que je
veux faire
soit senti que ça me faisait du bien
tout de suite j'ai les larmes aux yeux
qui sont montées je pense qu'à ce moment
là j'avais vraiment envie de besoin il
fallait que j'exclus auris mais bon on
peut pas extérioriser quand on est au
travail enfin comme tout le monde on a
des épreuves et on les garde pour nous
et puis on prend tout sur soi et je
pense que quand j'ai frappé dans le sac
ya plein de choses qui sortaient est
donc là j'ai eu un coup de coeur
enfin comme un peu des gens qui se
mettent dans ces jeux pensent ses actifs
je pense qu'on commence toujours un
sport de combat par rapport à une
histoire un peu personnel je pense parce
que sinon on peut aller dans plein
d'autres sports un peu moins dure un peu
moins violent mais en tout cas c'est ma
conviction je pense que c'est ça et à
partir du moment où vous tapez d'autres
ce sac
vous vous dites je veux dire très bonne
dans ce sport c'est pas juste dans d'en
faire un divertissement alors ça c'est
mon traître c'est ma personnalité qui
fait que quand je commence quelque chose
je fais toi l'extrême que ce soit au
travail n'importe quel projet je fais
tout à fond et tout de suite au bout de
quelques jours je me suis dit qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire pour faire un combat
déjà je voulais faire juste un combat
parce que j'avais la conscience qu'à 26
ans je pouvais peut-être pas être
championne tout de suite vos championne
tout court mais je me suis lancé le
challenge de monter sur un ring et de
connaître l'adrénaline d'un combat de
boxe mais à cette époque là on me dit
que c'est pas possible d'y danser trop
tard non y compris dans ce club de boxe
pourtant il y avait des grands champions
mais
donc du coup j'ai décidé d'aller dans un
autre club
où j'aurai peut-être plus ma place sid
ali voilà vous avez 26 ans oui bah nous
rêver c'est exactement ce qu'ont match
et c'est ça qui vous a motivé encore
plus selon lui parce que je sentais à
l'intérieur de moi que je pouvais le
faire ça s'expliquait pas c'était comme
ça c'était en moi je sentais qu avec
beaucoup de travail je pourrais je
pourrais y arriver à monter sur ce
fameux ring au moins une fois donc j'ai
changé de club et je suis allé au départ
dans un club a ouvert billet une usine à
champions dont sarah ourahmoune qui a
été médaille olympique à rio
s'entraînait donc c'était a ouvert
milliers chez saïd bennajem et je me
suis rendu en forçant le destin parce
que lui même à l'époque quand je donne
mon âge il n'est pas convaincu donc j'ai
dû le rappeler trois fois pour intégrer
son club et et de la l'histoire commence
c'est vrai que ça fait quand même nom
avant de vous accepter alors je lui
explique que j'ai 26 ans que je veux
devenir championne que je veux au moins
faire un combat on dit qu'il est très
occupé mais plus tard il m'explique que
c'est dû à mon âge et donc une fin bien
intégré le club j'ai dû faire mes
preuves sur un combat tu est d'accord
voilà mais je savais pas encore bosser
mais je pense qu'il voulait voir si ce
que j'avais dans le ventre est et
il a vu potentiel donc là vous avez déjà
perdu des kilos est tout sauf que j'en
avais déjà perdu quelques-uns
dans la salle de fitness mais je n'avais
encore beaucoup à perdre pour avoir un
corps athlétique et pour respecter la
catégorie de poids qui va avec ma taille
donc vous êtes quelques uns des poids
super plume l'huma nous sommes à plus de
9 kilos c'est 58,9 pour être précise
mais les kilos sont partis très vite
parce que je suis de passer du stade où
je faisais pas de sport petit peu de
temps en temps à beaucoup
intensifs à la intensifs et manger
sainement avec une meilleure hygiène de
vie donc c'était pas si toujours à
perdre comme j'aime
oui
et ce premier alors ce premier cours bas
sur les rings arrive quand à ça arrive
très vite c'est à dire que du moment où
je m'inscris à la salle de boxe à
aubervilliers à mon premier combat les
que deux mois d'accord ouais et alors
l'adrénaline et on sait comment alors
moi j'ai géré ça très difficilement
parce qu'à ce moment là il ya tout mon
entourage qui me dit mais qu'est ce que
tu fais mais tu fais n'importe quoi tu
prend trop de risques ta 26 ans c'est
trop tard ou alors concentre toi sur ton
boulot ou à la fin j'avais énormément de
remarques négatives j'avais pas grand
monde qui croyait du coup c'était très
difficile de d'être rassurés parce que
je trouvais aucun soutien ni à gauche ni
à droite donc j'ai très difficilement
gérer cette épreuve mais ça a été ma
force sur le ring le lors du premier
combat parce que je me suis un but un
peu battus contre finalement il a donc
premier combat et puis après on continue
l'entraînement alors déjà ce premier
combat c'était pour moi un combat test
pour mon entraîneur me prêterai plus
sociale parce que je savais que j'avais
pas le niveau technique d'ailleurs le
combat était était pas très beau à voir
c'était plus de l'engagement mais au
moins l'entraîneur m'a pris au sérieux
et de l'ag continuer la progression
de mois en mois et un an après seulement
je me fais du coup repéré par le
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france au
bout d'un an oui mais parce que je
m'entraînais vraiment de façon acharnée
la progression a été fulgurante je
travaille énormément c'est à dire que
même pendant mes horaires de travail à
l'époque j'étais commercial je vais
passer mon temps sur les poses à
regarder des vidéos de boxe le soir je
regardais des vidéos de l'étude eu la
passion quoi une addiction mais
l'addiction et donc il ya cette
progression quand il vient et qui vient
rouler très vite même pour quelqu'un qui
à cette heure là bas c'est comme c'est
comme tout quand on dit on travaille
beaucoup c'est pas qu'une phrase c'est
pas qu'un mythe un contrat rit beaucoup
on a les résultats très vite et les
bureaux alors ça arrive comment alors
les mureaux c'est donc au bout de deux
ans donc là j'intègre l'équipe de france
j'aurais une crise très vite commença
par un nombre dans le dans le sable dans
le sport dans la boxe anglaise et un
moment donné je m'entends plus trop avec
mon entraîneur de l'époque
j'en demandais beaucoup parce que
j'avais des ambitions qui était devenue
beaucoup plus hautes au départ voulait
être une petite box sympa qui connaît
quelques compétitions qu'après j'ai vite
voulu passer professionnel et en voulant
passer un professionnel j'ai demandé je
demandais beaucoup de temps et entraîner
en avait on n'avait pas autant
donc on s'entendait plus et tout de
suite je savais qu'il fallait que je me
tourne vers les meilleurs et les
meilleurs c'est au bureau il ya eu quand
même là un temps de réflexion parce que
c'était à 40 km de chez moi
vous déménagez
ménage pas tout de suite j'ai déménagé
récemment la pandera pendant plus d'un
an et demi même voir
lever paris les mureaux et des fois deux
fois par jour d'accord il est mûr le mur
au parisien c'est dire la volonté que
oui vous avez vous passé professionnel
de quelques couacs en mai 2010 9
décembre 2009 c'est vrai ça en fait
ouais c'est tout récent et 2019 et 2020
vous gagner le championnat de france
quoi alors du coup décembre 2009 fait
mes premiers combats professionnels donc
les gens fait trois que je remporte du
coup je sais que j'ai le niveau d'action
plaine de france mais arrivé en mars
le quotidien comédiens connus du couple
vous avez eu envie de vous oui je lui
eus je les u11 enfin j'ai eu en décembre
dernier d'accord mais il y avait la
crise sanitaire voilà qui fait que repas
organisé combat et c'est juste après mon
championnat très ouvert
deux victoires alors là j'ai six combats
six victoires pas de pattes des faibles
des fesses et de seins plana d'europe ça
va être contre une adversaire que vous
connaissez déjà bah là on est en train
de voir ça se peut que ce soit une belle
en tout cas la challenger officiel et
belges
de langue du titre le titre est vacant
d'accord
et elle a des magnifiques ceinture à sa
ceinture très belle ceinture donc la
ceinture de championne continentale qui
est
extrêmement belle et j'en suis très très
fière allure avec
hélas rien je me demandais un âge limite
pour pour des compétitions comme si je
sais pas il me semble que c'est 40 ans
il faut que je me renseigne dans
d'autres projets en boxe amateur je sais
que c'est différent on peut y aller un
boxeur à saint-jacques et qu'il a montée
jeu qui boxe plutôt bien à lui qu'est
revenue mais là vous pouvez progresser
encore sur un rush tous les jeux vous
avez vous avez senti beaucoup progressé
à oui oui oui du coup je suis dans ce
club là depuis deux ans et on voit une
nette progression j'ai complètement
changé de style avant j'avais un style
aérien plus tôt là j'ai un style de boxe
professionnelle un peu plus dur plus
physique et je continue la progression
avec mes entraîneurs les frères à l'ap
dont quasi la base il a qui font un
travail énorme qui ne compte pas les
heures et on travaille beaucoup beaucoup
pour devenir meilleur chaque jour
une journée donc c'est beaucoup
d'entraînements beaucoup d'abnégation
est ce que vous vous devez de quoi alors
j'ai moi j'ai fait beaucoup de
sacrifices donc au départ quand je
commence la boxe je suis commercial
ensuite je comprend vite que je dois
arrêter parce que ça demande beaucoup
trop d'entraînement beaucoup trop
d'heures d'entraînement que j'avais pas
en bossant du coup je me suis rabattu
sur la restauration
et c'était plutôt des extras par ci par
là c'était vraiment alimentaire
alimentaires même j'étais plus concentré
sur mes entraînements et même ça ensuite
j'ai dû arrêter déjà parce qu'elle le
confinement l écho évident mais j'ai pas
pu reprendre parce que le sport reprend
me demande tellement de temps et
d'investissement que je ne pouvais pas
travailler à côté donc ce que je fais
c'est que crasse déjà mes sponsors vous
avez des sponsors j'ai des sponsors
magnifique comme oxygène factory qui est
dirigée donc par laurent rochette g
pierre bédier donc le président du
département lentement qui m'accompagne
qui me soutient je vous avoue que c'est
seydou chercher encore des sponsors je
n'en cherche pas on a constamment besoin
pour financer
les préparations qui coûte cher pour
financer maintenant les combats parce
qu'il faut savoir que l'on travaille de
façon indépendante sans promoteur sans
organisateur donc tous les frais sont
pour nous pour le club mais on
hong haeran plus les idées les engrand
faire les choses en grand et on organise
des beaux événements donc c'est grâce
aux sponsors qu'on peut les organiser et
non pas ça des formidables cgt avant
propos de sa wii puisque est bien là
aussi ce que 1 finalement nous la crise
du coc vide pour nous dans notre club ça
nous a permis de nous réinventer et
d'organiser ces événements parce qu'on
n'avait pas trop le choix parce que les
organisateurs étaient prises en otage
puisqu'il y avait plus de billetterie
voilà du coup on s'est réinventé on a
organisé qui va organiser vos meux même
et maintenant qu'on peut travailler
autrement on a quand même décidé de
rester indépendant parce que ça permet
de créer une relation avec les
entreprises où on les met en avant par
de leur parcours de leur histoire mais
leur logo un peu partout dans tout le
monde est content
dans mon club non en france il y en a
une je crois qu'il y en a 300
merci merci alors vous suivront va pas
vous quitter comme ça
se suivent à vous voir voilà et puis à
vous soutenir et puis l'aspect lyon doit
gagner allez-vous 1 1 merci infiniment
merci
et donc ces voix là s'il ya des sponsors
qui sont intéressés il suffit de vous
contacter c'est très simple c'est ça
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir aussi merci
[Musique]